foreign
[Music]
which is obviously everyone's favorite
subject
in particular I'm actually here to talk
about a package called clock so clock is
a date time manipulation Library kind of
in the same way that lubridate is a date
time manipulation Library it does things
you might expect add date subtract dates
format and parse them all kinds of other
manipulation but but if you get anything
out of this talk it's really that clock
is not here to replace lubricate in any
way the only idea would be that in the
end clock might be a back end for
lubricate in the same way that DT plier
or DB plier are different types of back
ends for deep liar
and I'm not even going to spend the rest
of this talk talking about features that
overlap with lubridate instead I want to
talk about things that are pretty unique
to clock
one of those is safety
and one of those is calendars because I
only have five minutes I'm going to do
that with one date January 30th of this
year
safety is built into clock from the
ground up to hopefully avoid issues like
this time zone issues and validate
issues things that are pretty common
when you're working with time series and
just drive you up the wall
so let's jump into safety
here's a timeline this is January 30th
our date in question marked in Blue on
our timeline it continues through to
February on the next line You'll see
this gap between February and March
because February only has 28 days but
January had 31. so it doesn't
necessarily map one to one
if I were to ask you this seemingly
innocuous question
please add one to one month to this date
what would you get
well if we were to ask lubridate it
gives you a somewhat reasonable answer
of n a there is nothing that Maps one to
one from January 30th to Something in
February maybe
and there's nothing particularly wrong
with this except for the fact that it's
it's not the most useful answer
generally you'll be running this code
and it happens silently and then five
steps Downstream all of a sudden you
discover there's some n a's here like I
didn't have those to begin with where
did those come from and you have to
backtrack up through your calculations
to figure out why they appeared
if you were to ask clock this question
with ad months it actually gives you an
error in this special Case by default it
says whoa hold up there's something
wrong here go look at location one if
you had a vector it might be location
five seven whatever and check out the
invalid argument to learn more about
this case so you go and you look at the
documentation and you come out with the
idea that maybe I could set this thing
called invalid equals previous
that allows you to say
give me the previous valid date when I
have this kind of problem that's the end
of February I think that's a pretty
pretty reasonable result in this case
but you also might want to say depending
on your specific problem invalid equals
next to map forward to the beginning of
March instead
if you actually do like that Liberty
Behavior that's fine you can say invalid
equals n a and anytime that occurs
you'll get an N A instead
so that's about safety let's talk about
calendars
calendars are just the idea of a way to
represent a unique point in time with
our date in question we could use a
calendar called year month day to
represent this date using three
components the year the month and the
day of the month
but this isn't the only way you could
represent this date
you could also use the year and the day
of the year
or you could use one of these many other
calendar types that are built into clock
if you're a finance person you might be
particularly interested in year quarter
day which uses a true fiscal year to
represent your date
these are really nice because they're
all convertible to each other you can
work with any particular calendar type
and say you need to get the quarter out
you convert to your quarter day you do
manipulation over there you convert back
it's obviously convertible with date and
posix CT as well since those are the
date time types that you're most likely
to start out with
the other really neat thing that I find
really fun about these calendar types is
that they have what's known as variable
precision
these are all day Precision calendar
types at this point but we could narrow
that down to month precision as needed
and you've got a built-in year month
type in clock
similarly you could have a built-in year
quarter type
you can actually go the other way too
you can widen it out all the way to
nanoseconds if you need it
the last thing I'll say is that clock is
completely compatible with some of the
other packages you might be familiar
with that I've created called slider and
IVs slider is one for Rolling averages
so you can use clock types as the index
to say give me a rolling average looking
back four or five quarters
IVs is a relatively new package you
might not have heard of this one yet but
it deals with date ranges and you can
use clock types as the components of
those ranges
so to sum up Luber data is not going
anywhere don't worry but please try
clock for enhanced safety and these
powerful new types thank you
[Applause]
[Music]